and then I need to find a link to the
stream stream starting
all right
we are alive now I need to get the link
just in time for some construction nice
show you all love that all right let me
get a link copy URL yes
construction noise paste tweet oh yeah
oh yes this was not happening 15 seconds
ago but it's all good what is happening
guys I see the stream all right hi
so we got a pumpkin here this is purely
for for entertainment as we talk tech
but since it's kind of near Halloween
obviously it makes sense to have I have
some spooky tech topics that we can talk
through and I'll answer your questions
as well then I'll flip back and forth
wait for people to show up but what I'm
gonna do you can see this pumpkin here
is I'm gonna just be carving as we're
talking top-secret stuff I have an idea
for what I want to put on it but I asked
you guys for like a scary scary carving
idea and we got one yes oh yes yes slow
mode is on yeah there's there's a lot
I'm gonna try to read as much as I can
but let me I'm gonna wait for people to
show up while I draw on this pumpkin
this is going to be great
can you hear that on the mic
this the the democratizes kind of
seething
that'll be fun all right
top secret drawing inspiration what is
good closer to me or volume up just
how's that little better let's chat
about pixel to display issues sure
that's a that's a spooky topic and that
was actually one of mine so it's
actually only pixel to excel pixel to
excel phone of choice right now but it
had I talked about in my review I went
over pretty much all of my thoughts on
oh by the way this is fully carved and
empty which is awesome but I talked
about all the display problems that it
was potentially having that it could
that could affect you seems like there's
two seems like there's two main campus
people fall into with the display issues
with the pixel camp number one is you
know you look at it it looks okay it
doesn't look like the best screen in the
world but it's it's decent and it
doesn't really affect them you tell them
about the blue shift and they tilt it to
the side and they go I kind of see that
I wouldn't notice that if you didn't
tell me screen burnin I can't see it
unless you literally go full screen gray
wallpaper turn the brightness down and
look for it so a lot of people are like
that and they don't really care the
other half of people or the other camp a
lot of people have been falling into
lately there's gonna take a while this
is serious the other camp a lot of
people fall into is literally I saw some
people saying Google should recall the
phone like it's on I saw the word
unusable throwing out thrown around a
lot the pics with to display being
unusable simply unacceptable that they
would ship this it's an $850 phone which
is true I get it even 900 bucks
depending on where you get it or where
you're located
this would be faster this serious
business
oh wow yeah but those are the two camps
people fall into which is number one I
don't really notice no big deal or
number two recall the phone stop selling
it start over and I kind of fall
somewhere in between which is what I
said in a video but the thing is it
depends on you about obviously as I
tried to talk to both groups of people
in one video which is always fun to try
to do am i revealing my carving right
now not really okay I don't think it's
no big deal
because the display does look worse than
other phones in its price range but I do
think people saying they should stop
selling the phone are a little
exaggerating apples phones had the whole
bendgate thing bending in people's
pockets they didn't recall it there were
a antenna problems with phones they
didn't recall it the last film that they
really eventually had to recall was the
Galaxy Note 7 that literally started
exploding in people's pockets so to say
that they should stop selling a phone
with a slightly Knight as a good display
this is definitely gonna be harder than
I thought
but yeah that I don't think you have to
stop selling a phone because the display
is not as good you just have to know who
you are and if the display being not as
good affects you then it's not the phone
for you my phone a lot of people were
asking about my um display burnin
problems if I was having any I had such
a small amount that I would not be able
to discern it between that and just
temporary image retention I left it
there for a while it kind of faded away
it seems like it's not permanent but
that's a quality control thing because
some panels will have it and some won't
what are you doing I am carving very
sloppily the scariest pumpkin on the
face of planet Earth
I'm not even sure if I fully outlined
this what else is good
Android we're back in 2018 or is it dead
I kind of think Android wear is dead
right now I had a conversation the other
night
at with a youtuber actually at at the
Samsung event in the city about Android
wear and if it's dead or not or if
smartwatches in general are dead and the
conversation kind of went the same way
that it did about tablets our tablets
dead if it's not an iPad kind of yeah
our SmartWatch is dead if it's not an
Apple watch then kind of yeah I miss
Android wear I suggested that Google
could make some kind of pixel watch to
sort of rejuvenate that project it's
kind of like what the Moto 360 was or I
could punch it in and take it out
it's kind of like what the Moto 360 was
when it existed but then we were also
wondering like how many of those Moto
360s still exist on earth right now in
people's daily use and the consensus was
not that many love the videos thank you
shout out from India doing a good job
shout out to India Android wear I said
that already let's get spooky yeah this
is a little darker than the usual set
all right please work I really hope that
works
oh boy
I think it's work I think it's working
hey it did work all right
that's a good start oh don't break up I
broke off okay it didn't quite work but
it's better than I thought it would for
an upgrade from a galaxy note 5 do you
recommend the note 8s 8 plus Google
pixel to excel or should I leave Andrea
and go back to the iPhone 10 wow that's
a very open-minded person asking that
question if you're genuinely considering
all those things you probably can't
really go wrong with any of those a lot
of people when they ask like what phone
should I buy they're between like two
phones that's right
they'll get the idea but if you're
considering like any of those one two
three four phones I think any of those
would be good for you do I have a laser
and I have no lasers happening in this
any plans to release videos in HD are so
I think technically at this point my my
camera is already shooting in HDR and I
can just flip a switch in the gamma
settings in Final Cut Pro and it will
export a file that's the force HDR but I
just keep up like the the dynamic range
is not that different in my videos
between HDR and not HDR I don't have
that many crazy scenes maybe in like a
car video that could be interesting but
for now you kind of get the idea of
what's going on without HDR in the
videos but I might do it yeah a non tech
question have you ever considered
getting a motorcycle that's kind of
spooky
ah no I've never considered getting a
motorcycle because I need a trunk I
carry video gear two things I bring
video gear around in my car often so no
I've never thought about getting a
motorcycle because I can't carry it on a
backpack I need a trunk
this might be the most dangerous
livestream you've ever watched hmm your
phone needs to survive a super heavy day
say 10 a.m. to 4 a.m. and around at the
pubs and clubs you're not carrying a
backpack how do you charge 10 a.m. to 4
a.m. the next day huh first of all if I
know that day is gonna be such a long
day what I'm gonna do is charge wow I'm
gonna charge at any possible given time
during the day so I'm guessing you're
not out from 10 a.m. to 4 a.m. you're
probably out from 10 p.m. to 4 a.m. so
during the day you top up on maybe a
wireless charger or maybe a charge right
your desk you top up maybe when you're
driving that day in the car on the way
to work you plug up and go from 95 to
100 again basically take advantage of
fast charging so that when you finally
do leave for the day you're back out at
4 a.m. with enough battery I'm not sure
if that fully answers a question I might
have cheated with that but
mmm yeah this is good this is going well
it's going well okay yeah oh yeah okay
Sharpie is gonna be interesting later
what devices are u livestreaming from
this is a Canon c100 going into a
computer so straight HDMI capture cards
for the win yeah it's just putting the
pumpkin on the trash bag biggest
difference between Google home and
Google home mini ah to be honest they
are extremely similar which is a good
thing because Google home mini is like
half the price it's less than at the
price of Google home the biggest
difference is the speakers and the audio
quality and the sound and essentially
whether or not you use it to play music
Google home mini I don't think I would
use as a home speaker for any anyone but
Google home could pull it off that's the
main difference
Google home is bigger has more speakers
shout out to your channel so hey man hey
1 + 5 t a lot of people are asking about
that's something we've seen a lot of
rumors for there's a lot of rumors for
phones that are still coming out in the
next couple of weeks and I have a
feeling we're gonna be very busy on the
channel sharing those phones when they
come out with you sharing those in video
form so if you somehow stumbled across
this and aren't subscribed yet you
should do that so that you can see those
when they come out
oh that's actually not that bad and then
I gotta go
has this carving been given away yet do
you guys know what I'm making if so feel
free to guess alright
thoughts on the usability or lack
thereof of the bump on the display of
the iPhone 10 oh I thought you're gonna
talk about the camera bump on the back
you're talking about the notch the
iPhone tens famous notch I think people
will get used to it pretty quickly and
here's why I played with the essential
phone for a number of weeks which also
has a notch it's a little smaller but
it's the same concept had a notch in the
display took up some of the screen real
estate software worked around it ended
up not being so bad I got used to that
really easily Apple has a lot more
developers kind of on this side but
they're gonna have to go through this
little little awkward growing period
where developers and their apps their
apps don't play well with a knotch
and then they get updated and then they
look good I hope that that period does
not last for a very long time
I hope the apps get updated real quick I
hope Instagram and snapchat and all
those apps look great with the knotch
but I can't guarantee that so your
question was my thoughts on it yeah it's
gonna be weird at first but I think
users will get used to it pretty quickly
especially if all of apple's apps take
advantage of it alright this if I show
you guys what I take out of this right
now it's gonna give it away
ready someone guessed it already Harvey
Cox congratulations on guessing it but
I'm just gonna let people continue
guessing if people didn't see Harvey's
yes oh that's true essential phone is
$4.99 now you said don't spend your
money when it was $6.99 is it worth it
now
worth it it's an easier it's an easier
to stomach recommendation I was not
recommending the essential phone because
it was lacking a lot of features that a
lot of other flagships had at that same
price now that it's a lower price it's
still lacking those features so if you
still want those features you're not
gonna buy it
but if you were holding back on it
because it was too expensive now you
might be inclined to actually give it a
shot so again two different groups but I
think a lot more people will be tempted
to give it a shot at $4.99 not sure why
I took them so long to drop the price by
$200 but clearly they had that
flexibility should Apple bring back the
headphone jack no they should not
yeah yeah it sucks to say it but and if
you're gonna get rid of it and you're
gonna try to commit to making Wireless
better you should commit and don't bring
it back and that's the thing I've talked
about a lot people like to talk about
all the headphone jack I don't have a
headphone jack on this phone it's a deal
breaker I will never buy it that's cool
and I get it right now because Wireless
is not that good but I have a video
upcoming that I think will help explain
this a bit Wireless has to get good now
Wireless will have to get good now you
heard that click that's some plastic
moving carving Austin Evans face this
would be a lot of cuts for Austin's face
man
I was correct you guys know if you think
I'm that much of a artist that I could
carve some space into a pumpkin thank
you but I'm not oh man this is this is
making me appreciate those like actual
pumpkin carving kits a little bit more
just a little just a little bit more did
you get infected did you get affected by
the YouTube demonization I have not had
a sing I'm probably jinxing right now
but I have never had one of my videos
demonetized ever so no I haven't been
affected that doesn't mean it's not
happening it's happening to plenty of
people that are really not happy about
it
oh but as of right now even the video
that I made which was called had D
monetization in the title I haven't had
any problems I'm mostly a pretty
family-friendly channel if you haven't
noticed
oh man alright alright I'm impressing
myself with this based on what you know
iPhone 10 pixel to excel for MVP of the
year
Wow it's funny you pick those two phones
um only a handful of people know why
that's funny
but uh between those two phones yeah if
you want peer Android you're gonna want
to go with the pixel to excel if you
want pure iOS you're gonna want to go
with the iPhone ten simple as that
simple as that yeah yeah how people I'm
a carving my logo no my logo is not this
many cuts either excited for the D brand
grip any ideas when it will be released
yes I have a few ideas but I'm not
really gonna tell you them but uh yeah
it's pretty interesting I'm not a big
case person but a bumper is a different
prospect and it has some pretty intense
durability claims that you'll see later
do you have any mobile app ideas that
you would like to see developed oh you
guys are well not yet except for maybe
an mkbhd yet but not really under the
display touch ID is not going to be as
useful as it seems why complicate the
most frogs the part of the phone even
making it slower thoughts I don't know
about slower and to address your
complication concerns smart phones are
already insanely complicated adding this
is not this is so dangerous ah
adding the touch ID underneath the
display is not a complication concern
it's literally just is it possible yet
or not I think Apple would love to do it
I think Samsung would love to do it but
I don't think it'll have any negative
effects on the phone if you put it in a
phone thoughts on Android 8.1 enables
pixel there's a pixel visual court yes
okay so for those of you don't know what
that means
pixel visual core is if there's an API I
don't want to describe it incorrectly
but essentially what it does is it
enables third party apps to take
advantage of the image processing chip
in the pixel - if you didn't know the
image processing chip in the pixel - is
freaking amazing
it's what allow allows it to take
incredible pictures enables HDR on all
the time this is a little bit of it okay
but yeah Android 8.1 flips that switch
other apps can use it now so you can if
you like to take photos in third-party
apps like in pro if you don't have a pro
mode and you want to use pro mode you
can get an app from the Play Store and
take just as great photos up on this
yeah a little just a little bit cool all
right please extreme please explain with
a dumptruck plus kids swingy shirt means
the dumptruck plus kids swinging shirt
is no secret
it means dump swing not dumpster baby I
don't know if you thought it was that
dump swing is a Ultimate Frisbee term I
think I'll leave it at that
I'm actually carving hey guys in this
pumpkin man sup hello sub B sauce s8 or
no dates onset well no dates better so
there's that it's also more expensive
but she didn't ask oh yeah okay there's
gonna be a lot of this is gonna look way
better at night basically when you can't
see the Sharpie marks that I'm sloppily
carving around hmmm so shut off the
person who just put like 50 Canadian
flag logos in there shout-out to people
whose flags are also emojis
is there any suspense being built for
revealing this carving I think this is
kind of low-key a great idea thoughts on
the Google clips and the light camera oh
the Google clips is funny man I saw you
on must tweet at the verge the other day
when they posted about Google clips
which was I think you said like this
isn't even trying to be innocent which
is pretty funny because Google clips if
you don't know it's just this little
square camera that you just attach to
something near you pointed at you and it
will intelligently stay on forever and
take pictures when it thinks you want
them so yeah the the tweet was kind of
funny like this doesn't even seem like
you're trying to be like obviously
Google home you could you could put
Google home in people's homes and
they'll think well Google is not always
listening to me even if it accidentally
happens but this one not even trying I
think it's kind of an interesting idea I
don't think I would ever use it cuz I
consider myself a somewhat decent with
the camera but that's just me I don't
know I might like give it to someone to
try and see what they think
did I break this nope
love your channel super high quality
videos thank you
however somewhat disappointed in the
critical comments being removed from the
U 11 and picks with two videos yes I saw
that and I have never removed any
comments from that video one thing
that's interesting is people comments
get like automatically sorted by YouTube
so I saw like people saying Oh marques
removed a bunch of comments from the you
11 video I haven't moved a single
comment from that video but they just
get reordered and there's thousands of
comments and once they leave the front
page just based on engagement they're
really hard to find but I'm sure if
anyone who thinks their comment has been
removed goes to the email they got about
their comment with all the replies and
clicks the link they will find their
comment on the video again so if you're
disappointed with me don't be that's
just a youtube algorithmic thing that I
don't control Adobe CC to come to Chrome
OS in the near future that would be nice
a lot of people can't really use
Chromebooks because they don't support a
certain app they use all the time Adobe
being one of those app Suites so the the
pixel book just came out or the pixel
book reviews just came out and a lot of
people were basically comparing it to
you know should you buy this over an
iPad should you buy this over a Windows
laptop but the main concern they all had
was well it runs Chrome OS so the apps I
use are missing so yeah seeing Adobe
stuff on Chrome OS would be pretty
awesome
okay come on I mean stab myself in the
eye I'm just upgraded in my galaxy s7 to
the pixels to excel nice I notice the
camera is a lot more grainy in general
than the s7 this isn't normal is it
grainy grainy no there's plenty of noise
reduction going on with galaxy s7 but
there's also plenty of sharpening so if
it looks grainy er than normal may be
compared to other people's pixel photos
the pixel to excel is the best camera on
a phone so if you having problems with
it
return it RMA I get another one because
that doesn't sound right it's definitely
better than the s7 s camera let me clean
this up I just finished the carving by
the way but I'm gonna clean it up a
little bit cuz it's so messy how do you
how do you get your b-roll with the
phone standing up is someone holding the
phone up or what is the apparatus
oh it's here's the secret yeah you want
to grab one the secret to standing up a
phone like this is having something
heavy enough to stay behind it that's
smaller than it this is a red volt
battery you can do this with a salt
shaker you can do this with a whatever
else is about this size but just make
sure it's heavy enough so we'll put it
down and put your phone down
it doesn't knock that thing over and
hopefully you can see that but BAM
that's all it takes so anytime you see
those shots with the phone standing up
it's because there's something heavier
and smaller behind it
I literally bring those batteries around
I don't use them my camera's not
compatible with them anymore but I still
use them for that exact purpose
knife that up
yeah I'm knifing it up do you think
Samsung will over release a competitor
to the Amazon and echo and Google home
thing
Samsung man they have eyes didn't you
see like rumors of like a Bixby home
thing not that long ago I feel like they
might do it I don't know they're the
best idea ever but I feel like we might
see Bixby home and I might have to go
get one and review it cuz that's just
hilarious to me think about Bixby is a
lot of people don't really appreciate
Bixby can be really good but it somehow
like it can do a lot of things that
other assistants can't do but it can do
a lot of things other assistants can't
do but at the same time it gets a lot of
the easy stuff wrong somehow like you
ask it to like turn on the flashlight
strobe I need help in SOS in Morse code
and then like send an email to Grandma
with an attachment and it'll do all that
stuff and then you say by the way who's
the president and it would be like
searching web for bed resistant it just
doesn't know the simple stuff it's weird
so give away I mean yeah probably it's
probably giveaway coming uh-huh you have
a one plus three T 128 gigs should you
get a note eight one plus three T is a
pretty good phone still right now should
you get a note eight if you want one
note 8 is better so I'm not gonna tell
you not to get a note 8 but at the same
time you might want to keep waiting like
another couple weeks when some sweet new
phones coming out like from oneplus your
thoughts on essential camera performance
with google cam report yeah Google's
camera app is really good and using the
Google camera app on other Android
phones often results in better photos
than the camera app that comes on it so
I'm glad they put that in the Play Store
all right who's ready to see this
carving I feel like you'll be able to
see it no no it's good it's good we're
good
favorite color of iPhone X I think
actually I like the silver more because
the Space Gray is gonna be a fingerprint
magnet my current Space Gray iPhone it
looks pretty good right now but it's a
serious thing for magnet I'm probably
gonna go silver on my iPhone 10 we'll
see alright who's ready who's ready to
see the carving this is all live by the
way you saw me knifing this thing up
this is like a box cutter it's
definitely not made to cut pumpkins this
thick
I'm pulling it down oh there you go you
ready they're gonna review the pixel
buds yeah I need to get my hands on them
all right ready
here it is the spookiest
yeah we done did it I know I kind of
messed up on the one because I tried to
make it like it's hard it's hard to do
these things with a box cutter but I
think if you if you if this was
nighttime and you didn't see all the
Sharpie marks that I sloppily cut around
cuz the box cutter has no articulation
whatsoever that would be pretty good cuz
the light in it
by the way this light that's the lowest
brightness it gets can I sign this at
you higher highest is it glowing right
now yeah yeah I think it's a pretty is
that tube right now it's probably not
that bad yeah we did it guys everyone
don't know so don't switch to 144p I
didn't mean it like that I'm just saying
this is yeah are you biasing your videos
you've been accused i've accused myself
in a previous Q&A so one is asking about
bias and I think it's even in the title
of the Q&A where I talked about it
yes I'm biased I'm a human the only
unbiased you talk about reviews the only
unbiased reviews there are are the spec
sheet every opinion you give is subject
to the person that has that opinion and
if I say this display is nice even if
that's objectively true because it's a
high resolution and a high contrast
ratio and a high brightness and if I say
this display is nice even that is
subject to me liking that about a
display so that applies on every level
of every spec if you just give the raw
spec sheet fine I'll say you're an
unbiased reviewer but you aren't not
much of a reviewer then are you you got
to give opinions and that's what I do
oh you're telling me to say hey let's
get spooky should I do that what if I do
it on my phone will it work on my phone
I'm gonna say that
yeah mute that I'm gonna say it to my
phone let's get spooky ready to get
spooky all right ready
squeeze let's get spooky okay I'm
releasing the spirits now have fun
beware chromecast's and smart lights
won't be spared from this scare to stop
simply say ok Google
stop being spooky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
switch that by a champion that's
hilarious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I
[Applause]
how Isis keep your ID
oh hey Google ok Google
stop being spooky I don't understand
I said stop being spooky I don't
understand I'm just gonna wait I can't
all right I'm um no nope nope that is
hilarious though thank you for telling
me that that Easter Egg exists uh which
I'll think what would you give my rating
what do you what would you rate my
carving let me show it to you with the
lights off cuz it's sloppiest most
hilarious carving you may have ever seen
in your life what the lights lock you
can see I missed some lines and the one
is clearly a weird digit but give me a
number out of 10 give me a number out of
10 I feel like I'm gonna give myself
just because I was using this for most
of it and completely failed with this
I'm gonna get myself well you guys are
very generous I would give this a 7 out
of 10 for design but a 10 for spookiness
cuz that is terrifying zero out of ten
somebody said I 108 out of a hundred
thank you all right let's get the light
back in there oh did I have another I
had a another spooky text subject but oh
yeah the last part was obviously you
guys have seen Samsung ads in the past
I've been in several Samsung ads there's
another one that they just released I
tweeted about it
they were trolling real hard I guess cuz
obviously there's all these pixel to
excel display problems which are very
spooky that I just talked about well
super bright um but they they put out an
ad about Samsung screens I'm in the
thumbnail I'm in the video a bunch of
your favorite youtubers who make tech
videos
in the video and what i theorize samsung
is doing i don't have confirmation of
this but what i'm pretty sure they're
doing is they're they're paying for that
ad to show up for people who are
subscribers of those youtubers so if
you're subscribed to me and you don't
have youtube reading you see ads you're
probably gonna see this video today this
this ad will show up for you somewhere
on youtube if you're subscribed to and
this already been on his homepage on
like five people i knowes home pages
already if you're subscribed to like
other people in that video you're
probably gonna see that even more likely
yeah fun fact of the day
spooky samsung with they're sneaky ads
it looks better in 144p how alexander
how dare you pay to say that why would
you Wow how would you say that
yo saying that killed my cast of your
stream when I said stop being spooky
really Oh cuz I said to be spooky it
made yours spooky too yeah that's that's
crazy
good job Google what else can we talk
about we got this has been only 35
minutes that it took me to carve this
I'm gonna put it like right here
oh man what a good stream in which Q&A
did you talk about being biased I think
it's either the 19th or 20th one where
it's in the title so if you go to the
Q&A playlist there's one that says
biased reviews in the title it's that
one that's where I really break down why
being biased is people like to use it as
like an insult oh man you're so biased
thanks that's a compliment if I wasn't
biased I'd be the most boring reviewer
of all time at least you can calibrate
yourself to my bias if I say I like
certain things and then the next time
around you realize you don't like that
thing and I like it again at least I'm
consistent with my bias and you can
understand why that would be useful as a
reviewer then you subscribe to a bunch
of different reviewers who all have
different biases and then you can
calibrate yourself to each one that way
one they all make a video about the same
thing
you can watch all these different
reviews that give you the same opinion
about that device think about that
version 12 is how long ago Wow version
12 in January so the first ask him could
be HD the years when I went over that oh
that's one where I had to spray t-shirt
your sweatshirt that's funny I remember
that you laughed because it's spooky but
you have Wi-Fi at home that makes you
watch in 144p every time look I'm sorry
I didn't want that I wouldn't wish that
upon anyone but I understand this button
exists for a reason I just think it's
it's terrifying and I'm so sorry that
you have to go through that
when you're gonna start streaming on
Twitch
I have zero reason to switch to twitch
are there features that I don't know
about that twitch has cuz right now as
far as live-streaming goes just this Q&A
format could be fine on both but twitch
doesn't have the audience they're all
you guys are already on YouTube he
probably got a notification here twitch
doesn't have
I'm sure there are moderation features
in twitch chat but the fact that I have
we have super chat here and we have all
you guys logged in already you don't
have to make a new account that's pretty
important there's all the custom title
and thumbnail on the description
everything you guys are used to from the
typical YouTube experience pretty much
no reason for me to switch to twitch
even if I had gaming stuff there is
YouTube gaming I think I would stick to
youtube so yeah um
twitch is cool but any advantages of it
I'm clearly not privy to Spyder alert
well it's spider spider I hate spiders
by the way hopefully there's no spiders
anywhere how do you think do you know
when Apple will release an iPhone 10 sim
pre version I don't really know a sim
free version I'm talking about like the
embedded sim I'm not really sure what
that question means hey you sound like
my relatives can you fix my mom's
computer for me I probably can but I
would really rather not cuz you know
what happens when you you know happens
when your family tech support and you
fix someone's something if you fix
someone's printer then every time that
printer or computer breaks from here on
out you will get blamed for it and
you'll get asked to fix it again even if
it's totally unrelated I'm totally in
the way of the mic okay still it was my
audio fine I feel like I put the pumpkin
in between me and the mic
wait as a reviewer how stress to you
about getting an iPhone 10 on launch day
I think we're all pretty stressed that's
tonight
iPhone 10 pre-orders are tonight at I'm
glad this is kept going in the
background it's kind of appropriate
tonight at midnight Pacific time which
is 3:00 a.m. East Coast time which is
also apparently when stranger things to
there stranger things season two dating
his first episode or whatever oh the
whole season is that once oh that's why
people are psyched I thought it was one
episode all right that's fair that's
exciting but people will be awake then
for that reason that is pretty spooky
iPhone 10 supply at launch is pretty
spooky I'm gonna definitely melt this
I'm gonna turn it off it's it's kind of
one I mean the LED itself isn't that
warm but like the glass is getting a
little warm I'm gonna turn it off you
guys can still get the point of the
carving right yeah
what are they the last thing I saw an
article was a half of iPhone 8 supply we
already know how hard I phone eight was
to get it launched and people didn't
even really want I phone ain't that bad
people want i phone 10 billboards are up
for iPhone 10 hype is real for iPhone 10
supply not that good a couple million of
them allegedly you'll be able to camp
out at a store and get one but how many
is each store gonna have maybe it
doesn't that's rough that is spooky why
are the bezels so big on the small pixel
too it has the same DNA as last year
it's made by what HTC but really it
looks like you get those big speakers in
the top on the bottom and they didn't
spend a whole lot of extra on that
cheaper phone to get these thin bezels
in the big display great videos thank
you when you name your videos after
pixel to and then talk about the two XL
it makes it hard people who find stuff
on a smaller one yeah that's definitely
true I tried to talk about any
differences the thing about that is
those two phones are almost identical in
every way except the size of the battery
and size the display itself so you get
the slightly different shape
that I talked about a little bit box
here on the smaller pixel too but I
tried to I was very careful with my
language where every single thing I said
about pixel to excel was exactly the
same about pixel to unless I said
otherwise same incredible camera same
speaker quality as far as I know they're
not the same drivers but they're both
really good so battery life and the
displays were the things that are really
mainly different and hopefully that's
helpful in its own way alright a couple
more questions and then I'm gonna cut
the livestream and put this out in the
night and spook some people with it what
is that like it looked like condensation
but it's just I'm good what are your
thoughts on the pixel to screen burnin
issue should i cancel my pre-order I
don't think you need to cancel your
pre-order over a phone you've never used
if you are one of those pixel peepers
who will notice screen in screen burnin
despite its very very slight effect on
anything you do on the phone then ya
cancel it and get a good phone like the
no date has a great screen it's 200
extra dollars but if you're into that
they can get a great screen but I I
wouldn't cancel your pre-order over a
small quality control issue that may or
may not even affect you you can get the
phone and then see for yourself and I
think you can return it for within like
a month or something like that so yeah
don't cancel your pre-order or you might
never get one because this supply is so
small
what other we got a couple more couple
more tech questions we'll go to more
minutes can you play this live on your
iPhone can I write yeah I wouldn't want
you though cuz it would start echoing oh
my god Hasselblad went live on us again
I'm gonna live yes like tango live watch
my own livestream I want to talk about
the Nokia health app I have yeah okay so
I have people who probably noticed I'm
I'm just gonna have that Nokia nakiye
some people say no Kia health app
basically I have a scale a Wi-Fi
connected scale that had its own app
which is witting 's weddings had its own
app and i use it you know it tracks you
the different things that it knows about
you like the body fat percentage and
weight and all that stuff so I had these
little graphs and then Nokia bought them
I guess is what happened so there they
replaced that weddings app in the Play
Store with the Nokia app so one day I
just fired on my phone and instead of
the winnings app on my home screen
there's a Nokia app and I was a little
confused but I clicked into it and it's
the same functionality it's just a
little better-looking basically so
that's why that's there thank you I'm
glad you enjoy the videos is essential
phone the best phone at that price point
no it's not it's it's alright I guess
now that it's cheaper it's better among
its competition at that price but I
don't think it's yet the best phone at
that price point notice one plus five
gets forgotten a lot but it's that price
right now there's released a couple
months ago it's really good
pixel to camera or a small dedicated
camera well right now if I only want to
carry one thing in my pocket pixel to
camera is so good so I'd recommend pixel
to camera but if you want to get another
small dedicated camera you'd have to
spend a lot to get a camera better than
the pixel - you gotta have some extra
money and another pocket
and it's more batteries and another
charger you know I'm saying yeah - more
- more tech questions or - more good
questions so I'm just asking my chairs o
LG g3 and AB that LG v 30 please I have
my video on the best features of the LG
v 30 I guess he'd if I asked you guys
you'd probably say yes but I was kind of
torn about making another video about it
when all the things I'd be saying would
be pretty similar to what's in the top
five only things I didn't cover that
would be in a review would be battery
life and just long-term impressions of
the software and how its held up for my
use so I'm kind of tossed up about
making a video about it it might have to
be later that's the other thing about
the V 30 is the timing was so bad
they had that pre-release version that
they gave to all of us but now we have
iPhone 10 is about to come out that's
about to be that new oneplus phone is
about to be this new razor announcement
because about to be a whole bunch of
other stuff so by the time we get back
to be 30 hopefully it's still in on time
before the holiday season but clearly
they had some interesting timing there
all right uno mas here's my middle name
Kumar no okay bye
I was getting the same free version you
can buy without a carrier oh I don't
know I don't know if it's gonna be
different from the current iPhone 10 a
normal iPhone 10
anyway um I'm pumped about this 77 inch
TV playing that but yeah I've talked
about a lot of spooky stuff in this
stream I think the major takeaway is
spooky time a year that's pretty much
all I got
we're gonna go shut this down and go
back and hang out over on Twitter and
keep working on future videos there's a
lot of interesting stuff coming up so
also maybe some giveaways maybe a maybe
a really maybe a really really good
giveaway maybe pop if you're into that
if you're if you'd be down yeah anyway
alright that's pretty much it thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace